there's this clip going around on the
internet where a guy asked him did he
fail this season
do you get the promotion every year no
right so every year you work as a
failure no every year you work you work
towards something two years ago which is
to get a promotion to be able to take
care of your parents you work towards it
go it's not a failure it's steps to
success I love that Giannis did that
because there's so many comps to it
right now A lot of people are realizing
what athletes are dealing with because
now everyone's putting themselves out
there and they're getting commented
about everything about everything about
everything one bad night and everyone's
got all sorts of things to say every one
of us in this room right now we have bad
days but it's hidden it's a very
interesting human psychology
conversation I love that that Viral clip
is going because I hope it helps people